welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
is now on digital revealing all kinds of
new interesting VFX details specifically
some really cool stuff about Groot that
was just too easy to miss when we first
saw it in theaters I had a chance to sit
down with two of the frame store VFX
artists who worked on this film Alexi
watchbro and Stefan naze who confirmed
some fascinating visual elements in the
design of these characters I'm gonna
break it all down for you now I dive
deep into the Guardians of the Galaxy
Trilogy on the Deep dive Channel part of
our growing Network that includes this
main Channel and our newest channel the
break room subscribe to all three and
support our network with a scroll
inspired shirt from nerd riot.shop okay
recently James Gunn confirmed a long
time mystery about groot's origin teased
nine years ago and the very first
Guardians of the Galaxy film how did
Groot and Rocket meet and groot's
booking screen on xandar in the first
Guardians of the Galaxy one of his
associates was named tibia's Lark
someone James Gunn hinted would be
explored in future film but as of
Guardians volume 3 we have never met him
but now gun confirmed on threads that he
did right storyboard location scout and
shot test footage for a short film a
piece of which was shown in the footage
screen at Comic Con last summer that
would have been part of Guardians volume
3 and would have shown rocket Groot and
someone named tibia slark imprisoned in
a deep well on the ground tibius was
dying and had been caring for Groot for
years he was a former zookeeper in a
shitty Galactic Zoo where Groot had been
on an exhibit and to be a saved group
but as tibis died he made rocket promise
to take care of Groot and then rocket
realized tibis's bottom half was robotic
in the guards above the well would have
seen Groot bursting out of the ground
and Racket on his shoulder and in
Rocket's hands would be a machine gun
made from tibius Lark's body I think
this is a fascinating story and I shared
with you because when you re-watch
Guardians volume 3 you can totally see
elements of this backstory coded into
the VFX animation throughout the film
let's start with Groot I specifically
asked the frame store artists and then
we had all those
discussions in terms of all the bugs and
badly or device how they should move the
idea was not to feel any stretch you see
that because it's it's done with wood so
that's something you want to feel
basically when you have like root a
badly acting also the idea was really to
feel like something quite suffocated but
not too distracting the idea was not to
have all the pieces moving all over the
place yeah so Stefan explains how
groot's branches aren't stretchy or
elastic but really are just unfurling
pieces of himself that are folded up and
rolled up inside of his chest why did
they make this distinction well because
if you were to make Roots branches to
elastic they would start to look snaky
like bungee cords with a mind of their
own but by keeping the branches more
rigid they feel like extensions of Groot
himself each fiber moving as an
intentional decision by Groot and
knowing this it makes the No Sleep till
Brooklyn Wonder especially fun to
re-watch especially now in high def
where you can really go through frame by
frame to see all the little things they
hid in there like watch Groot in a
sequence for the early part of the
sequence we really just follow groot's
Branch arm as it swats two of the
hellspawn soldiers and then for the
third Stuffs the arm down his throat and
then grows sharp branches out of the
flesh killing him from the inside out
then Groot keeps this same arm extended
longer than he should why does he do
that well it's to get mantis time to
swing from the branch and then latch
onto the shoulders of the guard in the
foreground and then flip that guy
backward back into groot's arm to
clothesline him and you can hear the
guard's bones breaking when he hits
groot's arm
it's just such great choreography and if
groot's arms were snaky and elastic for
this they wouldn't have had the weight
or the rigidity or the resistance
required for all of these moves then as
far Groot takes a stab to the Torso the
Rocket jumps on that hellspawn's head to
shoot him then hops on groot's shoulders
giving us a call back to the Kiln
sequence and the first Guardians of the
Galaxy movie and then rocket runs down
groot's arm as it grows down his quarter
once the arm reaches its growth limit
Groot flips rocket in the air giving
rocket some height in this hero moment
as Rocket laughs into light
[Music]
so groot's branches always represent
strength and confidence and supporting
his friends not elastic cheating or
trying to bend its way around the rules
of nature we also see this earlier in
the movie in the shot when Groot leaps
out of the window to catch quill and
make wings
and if you watch this closely you
realize it's not just the branches that
make the wings it's the leaves growing
off of the branches that provide the
lightweight wind resistance to function
as a true parachute it's really
impressive to think how these VFX
artists really thought all this Anatomy
through and thank you to better help for
sponsoring this video here at new
rockstars we like to figure out what
makes movies work go frame by frame to
figure out what's really going on but
when we need Insight on what's really
going on with ourselves we use better
help betterhelp is the world's largest
therapy service and it's 100 online with
better help you can tap into a network
of over 30 000 licensed and experienced
therapists who can help you with a wide
range of issues to get started just
answer a few questions about what you're
looking for from therapy and what your
preferences are better help will then
match you with a therapist from their
Network that's right for you after that
talk to your therapist however you feel
comfortable whether it's via text chat
phone or video call you can message your
therapist at any time and schedule live
sessions when it's convenient for you if
your therapist isn't the right fit for
any reason you can switch to a new
therapist at no additional charge charge
better help gives you the same level of
professionalism and quality you expect
from in-office therapy but with a
therapist who is custom picked for you
more scheduling flexibility and at a
more affordable price get 10 off your
first month at betterhelp.com new
rockstars that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p.com new rockstars
for 10 off your first month of therapy
now the hellspawn characters their lower
halves are robotic and obviously that's
also part of the design of the
co-occupants of rockets batch 89 cage
and I think their visual similarity to
what James Gunn had in mind for tibius
Lark might be why the Lark backstory was
removed from the film it could have just
been he didn't want people to think the
two characters were connected or that
tibia slark was also a creation of
Herbert window James Gunn shared some
sketches containing new details about
Lila floor and thiefs that their numbers
are respectively for Lila 89212 for
floor 89j50 which is later changed to
89l06 and then for tease 89A 95 and the
notes you can also see the James Gunn
wrote for floor metal jaw moves scrapes
on self when talks that could be why
Flora speaks so childishly originally
whenever she talked her metal jaw was
gonna scrape her body
does it work now I asked the frame store
artists about this and how they chose
the exact look of things like thief's
motorized eyelids her floor's mouth
Falls the implants they wear them also
in the in the original concept but it's
it's a sketch so these guys are doing
experiments and they take whatever they
have next to them it could be an old
pipe it could be an old rotor it could
be and we a bit macgyvery and so we take
that and and we find references of old
motor of plane or anything we have and
we use that as reference to make them an
old speaker for the mouse a floor oh my
God he went on to describe how they went
back to look at the implant on Rockets
back in the first Guardians of the
Galaxy and from that worked backwards to
justify how a quadruped animal would
need to be given a new backbone and
shoulder blades to pull his arms back so
that he could walk upright essentially
they had to play God and put themselves
in the headspace to the high
evolutionary to rethink how these
animals would move a different way with
practical Parts swapped in now a deleted
scene that came out last week confirmed
that the high evolutionary did survive
the final battle and that he was locked
up in a prison out on nowhere by rocket
and we pointed out in the past video
that you can see the exact moment that
Drax carries him off the exploding ship
and now in high resolution you can see
the high evolutionary draped over drax's
shoulder but that's not the only cool
detail hidden in this moment Alexi from
frame store pointed out other fun
details that they threw in among the
animals flocking off this ship if you
look at the second you have a monkey on
top of
you have some turtles on top of and
those are Tapia like you have animals on
top and then also on all of these
stickers there is little story of
animals continuity between the shots
animals on top of animals
you could definitely see a monkey
writing a taper here and then on their
tapers in the background Turtles are
open it's eat one of those little
turtles just slowly making its way
across the great I love these animals
working together because it shows how
these are not lower life forms they're
just all animals capable of cooperation
and teamwork there are so many new
details like this so we're discovering
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3. so here's
the plan we are gonna do a brief
breakdown of this film coming out on
this channel sometime this month
remember to subscribe to all three of
our channels and support us by grabbing
some merch at nerd riot.shop follow me
on Instagram and Twitter at eavos and
we'll see you next time everybody bye
[Music]
thank you